a guy at work sexted me these are
all like very naughty awkward situations
i feel set up
[Music]
i played a game called oy that's awkward
with jesse tyler ferguson and cheryl
hines
where we gave advice on how to handle
awkward situations
okay so your boss calls you by the wrong
name
do you a correct her b become a new
person
i'm continuing that today with awkward
situations y'all submitted on the
internet so let's do this
[Music]
i accidentally sent a text i was writing
about someone to them
how do i undo this major mistake i can
tell you what you need to do
every time i write a text i proofread it
i
check who i'm sending it to and also
maybe you shouldn't be talking smack
about somebody and maybe you should aim
higher i'm just saying
like you know what when you're talking
smack about them you're wasting your
time not theirs
just saying there's a self-help book um
just
waiting to be read
[Music]
um one time a woman came up to me and
started chatting and she knew everything
about me but i had no idea who she was
that's
awkward i swear i had never seen her in
my life and i didn't know what to do
help um yeah that's when i just lean it
like i
this has happened to me too and i just
say oh my gosh i am so so i'm not trying
to be
a turd i just i'm blanking like you're
out of context for me right now like i'm
so sorry like
and all you can be is honest and if they
get mad they weren't really a really
good friend anyway
so godspeed
what do i do when i'm sitting next to my
parents
[Laughter]
when i'm sitting next to my parents
during a sex scene in a movie it's so
uncomfortable
actually i can give you some pretty
solid advice on this one because
i was in a movie theater watching this
is years ago and i was with my sister
and my mother
and we were like let's go to the movies
i think i was on tour and
there wasn't really much to do we were
kind of a small town
and we went to the movie theater and i'm
not talking like a normal
sex scene i'm talking like graphic like
i was like
this should be labeled a different type
of movie kind of movie
and i felt so uncomfortable and i'm not
like an uncomfortable per obviously i
have no filter like i'm
you have to do something pretty weird
for me to be like you know what this is
i my sister and i both looked at each
other and we were i mean i couldn't sink
any lower
into the theater seat and finally i just
got up and said i need to go to the
bathroom and i didn't i just stayed
outside of my car
and my sister came out and she was like
oh my god that was kind of awkward right
like it was kind of a lot like in my
family like we can handle a lot
so when we're saying it's a lot it might
be too much so
um the best part of this story which my
mother's gonna kill me for
is she stayed and watched the whole
movie
she was like she came out and this is
such a southern mom
she came out we were in the car just
like she is still
in there watching this crazy stuff i
can't swear i can't stay on right now
and anyway she comes out gets in the car
and is like
um you guys i mean i can't we were like
how did you stay in there like what how
how are you not feeling uncomfortable
like
even with your daughters but like
strangers like how are you not feeling
uncomfortable in general
and she was like i just can't believe i
mean that was so rude of y'all just to
get up and leave the theater
and leave during the show and and i was
like
what anyway the southern mama
politeness before anything else it's
awesome
a guy at work sexted me and i these are
all
like very naughty awkward situations
i feel set up um i got i don't care
a guy at work sexted me and i turned him
down
but now i have to see him every single
day what should i do here's my first
question
what does that mean and does that mean
he just asked her out or did he say
something like
like what is it's a vulgar attack a
vulgar texture
like do this to you oh okay okay and
then
so this person had my number
whatever long story and he texted me
and started texting me about like
literally the first text he said this is
years ago
at first text he sent me was like you
have a nice
and i was like i literally
sent back charming this is why this girl
or person turned you down
like that's like after a while in the
relationship this has been awesome
sorry mom